Anyway,
MMA math is ridiculous.
It doesn't work.
And you might be the best example of how it doesn't work.
But so you go to this,
the,
the Mayo Clinic puts you on antidepressants because you just feel like shit.
Well,
I feel like shit.
And because like of the,
the different endocrine problems that I had,
right.
So I can't have,
um,
any of the medications that'll help that.
So I have to be more conservative with it.
And one way they thought to do it is because my cortisol levels are really high.
They're talking about,
um,
and I mean,
granted I have a lot of stress,
especially like,
you know,
life hasn't been easy.
That's a single mom.
Your husband passes away.
You're in the toughest,
probably the toughest sport on the planet.
I'm trying to be the best at it.
Yeah,
you're elite,
you're in the top 10.
So you're,
you're in this weird position where you never know when you're going to fire to
who you're going to find,
does it constant amounts to,
and it's not like you're making millions of dollars doing it either.
No.
Well and it's expediting healing for me in,
and I also have a kid going through what I'm going through,
so it's not like I get to like split and cut corners and just,
you know,
it's like there's maintenance to be done at all times with that.
So I go there,
they tell me,
you know,
we could probably lower your coders all levels if we could load or lower your
stress levels.
So we'll try it.
Antidepressants,
what did that make you feel like?
Flat as fuck and like I didn't am I came up,
can I say fuck on this?
Okay.
I know,
I just didn't know if I have a quota.
I'm like a bad person.
Like did I get handed to like a Doug get added to a certain level,
zero restrictions.
You can say whatever you want in the shade on right.
Done.
Okay.
So there's no one listening.
Okay,
got it.
Um,
so yeah,
they,
they put me on,
they usually have flat flat,
which like all that training camp getting ready for Juliana.
I'm just like,
I'm like,
okay,
I'll,
it'll,
it'll take off in the fight.
Like,
I feel good in the fight.
Like when they say go and run the loon,
that no,
no ups,
no downs,
no,
no pissed off,
like want to kill,
you know,
nothing,
and show,
not scared but not happy.
No.
And I was like,
why am I not nervous the way that I get nervous?
Like,
like,
like I was okay.
Which you usually like,
especially two weeks out,
I have this like flesh of emotions,
you know,
where I'm like,
fetal position in the corner,
like what the fuck?
And then once it's over,
all I want to do is kill,
you know.
But,
uh,
again,
I didn't have that either.
What kind of made me nervous because my,
my other friend buyer pancheck we,
she,
she's a new 20 fiver.
Um,
we would always like call each other and laugh at how dumb we are being at that
point.
Like,
look at me,
you know?
And uh,
but that was all gone with the,
yeah,
but what should,
did they put you on?
Um,
oh,
is this one?
Oh my gosh.
So off Paxil,
keep going.
Um,
Prozac,
what do they have?
Uh,
do you know what I mean?
Jamie affects her fixer,
the fixer and James playing stupid over the
crazy pills
twice a day.
Just kidding.
Just tic tacs
tries them out.
Um,
so,
so they put you on this stuff and did they try different ones?
Uh,
no,
because,
uh,
not a lot of time there isn't it?
You know,
and,
and they're looking,
I'm like,
I need the side,
the side effects matter.
Like these can't be ones that made me gain a bunch of weight.
Right.
They can't make me like,
like I need to still be able to sleep.
Like I have to be able to have like enough highs and lows to be able to function
and learn and,
and whatever.
And so this is like the best they,
they could have for me.
So anyway,
I,
I fight that fight with Juliana.
You know,
I,
I feel like the first round I came out how I wanted,
you know,
and then halfway through the second round,
like it was just awful.
Like she had my old coaches in her corner.
You know what's weird about that fight is I could hear you and I could like I,
this is where the flat came in is like I wasn't,
I didn't feel like I was in the fight.
Like I could see herb Dean's feet and I could hear you talking about us and I,
I saw like I could hear Juliana's coaches and it was breaking my heart that they
were coaching against me because they were my Colorado gym and she went and
trained with them and I know she had trained with them previously.
So I mean before she had taken a fight.
But to me it was like fucked up to here,
you know?
And it hurt me in a way,
like it's,
I wish I could explain it better,
but it was like I heard them and I just wanted to go home.
You know,
I look at the clock and I'm like,
kitten,
this just be over.
I don't want to go back to Colorado.
I want to move like in and I literally on this side of the cage,
I had my past in Colorado,
I had these coaches,
I had the drama with that,
with that Jim,
like how everything went and,
and then on this side it was like all new problems like San Diego,
Eric,
and then we're good.
Like there was a lot of shading partners there.
It was sunny,
it was similar to Colorado at different but in the right ways,
you know,
and it's like,
okay,
I just wanted it out of fight.
You were in San Diego trainer for that fight or no?
Yeah,
I can't,
I just flew out for it.
For,
for the training camp and why you flew out there,
you were still taking the antidepressants and did it,
did that fight convince you to stop taking them?
Yeah.
So after that fight I went to a,
what did I do?
I think I went to the,
I was at the Pi,
I was working with Novinski and people on like what to do about that.
I haven't talked to Gordon,
Dr. Gordon,
Mark Gordon,
yeah.
To,
um,
help me with all of that too.
Cause he thought there was a more conservative way to help me with those issues
as well.
And so I knew I was talking with him.
I had him talk to them.
Uh,
they were all trying to figure out a way,
but so there's like,
there's no way to even just naturally bring you up to think about retiring.
Yeah.
And that,
that's the thing is the center was really the place that was,
is like,
okay,
I'm going to go here.
I've tried everything else.
I'm going to go here and if they can't fix me then,
then I'm,
I'm going to have to be done.